how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
tonight
is the night the loki series finale
a lot is about to go down and the mcu is
about to be changed forever
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios has already stated that loki is
an
extremely important series in fact he
said it was the most important series so
far
and it's going to have a big impact on
the mcu
and we can probably assume that the tva
is going to be taken down and no longer
exist
after the finale essentially causing the
multiverse to
reappear that is unless the tva was
lying and they actually didn't prevent
the multiverse and there's been a
multiverse this entire time
however i do believe there is one sacred
timeline
but after this it's just going to blow
up and that's what we're here to talk
about today the loki scenes that we have
not seen yet that have been shown to us
in the trailers
break those down and talk about our
final predictions on what is going to
happen
during this finale who exactly is going
to be the villain and what is going to
happen
moving forward i'll break down the best
predictions on what we're going to see
tonight in this video
also i'll be having my watch party at 11
30 pacific time tonight if you want to
join me
and of course if you love marvel be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification
bell so you don't miss out on any videos
now first things first i want to clarify
one scene because those people over at
marvel studios are super super sneaky
a lot of people have been posting online
the scenes that we haven't seen yet
and usually what's included is this
scene right here
loki about to walk through a portal with
some rocks behind it however this photo
is a lie
it is simply an edited scene that they
edited to put in the trailer and not
give away
sylvie i believe this was in the very
first trailer
before everybody knew about sylvie so
they obviously did not want her in it
but in reality it is this scene right
here where loki and sylvie are on
lamentis and they get taken by the tva
or
save depending on how you look at it but
the two portals open up and the two of
them
go through the portals sylvie and the
other portals have simply been edited
out and from here we pretty much go
in order of scenes that we haven't seen
yet at the end of loki episode 5
loki and sylvie enchanted eliath
removing him from what he was protecting
a castle and the person in charge of the
tva
and thanks to these scenes we know that
loki and sylvie get
inside the castle as we see here loki
walks right up to the front door and we
could probably assume that silvia's with
him but she has been edited out of this
trailer shot as well to avoid spoilers
they were holding hands the last time we
saw them so i assume they're going in
together now as loki gets in
he goes through a very very long hallway
and you can notice on the very front
door and in the halls and on the floor
it looks like it's cracking like it's
breaking almost like
reality is breaking and i have a theory
that these cracks could actually be
caused by branch realities being created
therefore kind of putting a crack in the
sacred timeline and since this castle is
made by whoever controls the sacred
timeline
the power could be connected we know
this because in the mid-season trailer
that marvel gave
us in the very beginning it starts off
by showing us the sacred timeline
it looks like it's in the middle of
space or could it be in the quantum
realm
that is one theory but next to it we see
a rock but this is more like a giant
floating meteor rock
because as we see on top of it there is
a yellow glow
and this yellow glow is the tower of the
castle that loki and sylvie are about to
go into where the creator of the tva and
the sacred timeline is
then we have a scene with sylvia inside
of the castle and it definitely looks
like she's fighting
however it looks like this scene is most
likely edited as well
but notice what the background looks
like it actually kind of looks like
doctor strange's sanctum
now there have been theories that doctor
strange or a master of the mystic arts
could be behind all of this
but i don't think so i think more than
likely and now more than ever
we still only have two options of who
the actual villain is of the loki series
however i will discuss three theories
two that i think
are very likely and one that is actually
likely
but i don't really want to happen it
will honestly break my heart
but we'll get to that let's first talk
about king loki
now we actually have a picture of king
loki from the trailers
and this was actually shown in a few
different trailers as we see here it
looks like he is clearly king of asgard
other asgardians are beside him most
likely royalty or diplomats and they are
clapping for him it is very obvious that
he is the ruler it looks like this could
be our villain however
as we know marvel does like to deceive
this could simply be a scene
where whoever the main villain is is
showing loki what he could have
obviously whoever controls the sacred
timeline could tell loki hey
i control everything i can send you on
your own timeline and you can do
whatever you want you can rule asgard
you can rule earth
whatever you want i'll make it happen
but knowing art loki that's not really
going to be good enough for him or
silvi they don't want to be a part of
the tva or a part of whatever this time
creator has made they want freedom they
want chaos they don't want to be
controlled they don't want to have
a destiny which is why it would make
perfect sense that a
king loki could be the villain because
loki is the person who wants control
they don't want to be controlled but
they want control they believe that they
are destined to rule and they believe
that it is easier for people when they
are being ruled and since the show
is all about loki it would make perfect
sense that in the end
the villain is a loki variant we also
have a scene where loki is looking into
some sort of an object he turns around
and says glorious
and there's quite a debate on what this
scene could actually be
some people think that due to the
background it looks like he's still
inside of the stark tower and this could
be some sort of a flashback to something
he said or he could go back in time and
actually win
whereas some people think that this is
some sort of a magical object that lets
him see
through different parts of time perhaps
this is our loki dressed in his
asgardian gear and again somebody could
be showing him something that could
come true a life that he could have but
at the same time i think this actually
could be a
king loki looking through this object
monitoring art loki and sylvie and when
they finally get to him he turns and
says
glorious it's very hard to tell from
this quick little one second scene
but of course it will all be revealed
tonight now the second prediction of who
the main villain could be
is the one that i really don't like
because it's the theory
that sylvie could actually be the
villain in the end it was sylvie all
along and she'll end up betraying
arloki now i really don't want this to
happen because i think as far as
character
arc is concerned our loki has really
grown and i do think he really does
love sylvie in whatever way that may be
but she does seem to be more on top of
things than are loki and after all she
had been planting her plot of revenge
for a very very long
time since she was taken by the tva as a
little girl this
will definitely be sad to see and
honestly arloki could even betray her
which is something that i really don't
want to see either
i either want to see the two of them get
together in some way shape or form
however weird that may be or i want to
see them part ways
happily but i really want sylvie to
stick around for a long time
there's been word that season two for
loki has been confirmed and it would be
great if arloki and silvi could come
back for that
now for the third theory of who the
villain could be is actually the theory
that i've been stating since the very
beginning of the series
however i give you a new twist i still
believe it's king
however i think it is a variant of kang
and not the true king that we're going
to be seeing in ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania who i believe this
character could
actually be is a mortise and the reason
is i think there has been too much
evidence pointing towards king for kang
not to be involved in some way shape or
form now for those of you who may not
know nathaniel richards is actually
kang's name and nathaniel richards has
actually had many different names
depending on where in time he is at
and what he's doing he's been the
pharaoh rama tut and when he started
conquering he deemed himself king the
conqueror
and then at one point in time he becomes
a mortise and that's who i think we may
be seeing
because listen to this story in the
comics king the conqueror has done a
pretty good job and he's conquered a lot
of different planets and timelines
then the three time keepers who were the
only living beings left in their
timeline at the very end of time
go to nathaniel richards aka king and
plead with him to try and make a deal
and they say how about instead of
conquering everything you actually help
us save everything
and in return we will grant you
immortality
king then accepts the offer from the
three time keepers
becomes immortal and then he calls
himself a mortis
from here a mortise would exist in limbo
that's where he would live and limbo is
a place that exists outside of space and
time
kind of sounds like the tva right in
limbo is chronopolis his home
and this could be where his castle is in
the void the void
is essentially limbo which means that
castle could very well be kings or
should i say it could be immortus's
after all ravona rinslayer who is kang's
lover in the comics seemed to believe
that the timekeepers were real
and perhaps they were real at some point
but then they died
leaving immortus to be the ultimate
controller of the sacred timeline
however he kept up the facade of the
three time keepers
this is what i think we could be seeing
tonight i definitely think loki is going
to be setting up kang in some way shape
or form but i think tonight we'll see
a mortise honestly right now i'm 50 50
on whether or not i think we're going to
be seeing king loki or immortus i think
since the show is so
focused on loki that may be who the
villain is but we've had so many easter
eggs for kang
i don't see how they don't at least set
up king the conqueror in the finale or
in the post-credit scene of the finale
but let me know your final predictions
for who the villain is and what is going
to happen in the finale
in the comments down below and don't
forget to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me